go away Ian that's a message from Tampa
Bay Area residents who have not taken a
direct hit from a hurricane in a hundred
years
this one does feel a little bit
different we felt that way in the past
before so it's just better to be safe
than sorry with time running out
residents rushed to fill sandbags
bored up businesses and homes
and stock up on supplies many shelves
are empty as many as two and a half
million people are under evacuation
orders they say mandatory evacuation
it's time to go as a massive lightning
packed hurricane makes its approach U.S
President Joe Biden warned residents not
to be complacent your safety is more
important than anything and I know our
hearts are with everyone who will feel
the effects of this storm and we'll be
with you every step of the way we're not
going away the message from State
authorities is more direct if they heed
the evacuation order I have a 100
percent guarantee that they will not die
from storm surge if they heat the
evacuation order I have a 100 guarantee
that they will not have to be rescued
off a rooftop if they heed the
evacuation order NASA officials
scrambled to move the artemis-1 rocket
off its launch pad and back into the
Vehicle Assembly Building at the Kennedy
Space Center
it took about 11 hours to get the rocket
back into the building
a hurricane hunter aircraft known as
Miss Piggy was sent into the eye of the
storm over the Caribbean
the information gathered by the
high-tech gear on board indicates that
the storm will intensify even further
when it moves over the warmer Waters of
the Gulf of Mexico
it also indicates that storm surges
could see the water level rise as much
as 10 feet along large areas of the
Florida coast and the impacts are going
to be far far broader than just where
the eye of the storm happens to make
landfall in some areas there will be
catastrophic flooding and
life-threatening storm surge
the mounting fear that no number of
sandbags will be enough
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera